Larry P Arnn is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University
graduating with the highest distinction
he received his MA in government and a
PhD in government from the Claremont
Graduate School he also studied in
England from 1977 to 1980 first as a
research student in international
history at the London School of
Economics and then in modern history
at Worcester College Oxford University
while in England he also served as
director of research for Martin Gilbert
now Sir Martin of Merton College Oxford
and the official biographer of Winston
Churchill he returned to the United
States in 1980 to become an editor for
public research syndicated and from 1985
to 2000 he also served as the president
the Claremont Institute and educational
and Research Institute based in Southern
California while at Claremont he was the
founding chairman the California Civil
Rights initiative which passed by
California voters in 1996 prohibited
racial preferences in state hiring
contracting and admissions dr. Arnn is
on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Army War College
the Henry celebratory Center of
Claremont McKenna College and the
Claremont Institute published widely in
national newspapers magazines and
periodicals on issues of Public Policy
history and political theory is the
author of Liberty and learning the
evolution
of American education published
published by Hillsdale College press in
2004 this morning you will speak on the
topic self-government or Czarist
bureaucracy certain will be very
interesting we could go on with listing
his accomplishments but on a personal
note I think some of his finest
accomplishments are that he's a very
fine speaker but more importantly a very
fine educator I'm very glad that we can
have met Hillsdale College very proud to
say that he is our college president
please join me in welcoming dr. lair
Thank You Dylan
Dylan's daddy runs a pheasant shooting
Nirvana is that true in Aberdeen South
Dakota I've not been there yet but it
looks beautiful I am an old man now and
I'm a teacher by trade and that means
that when I talk in this room I my eye
goes to all these people that have grown
up around me yeah Dylan is not the
squirming freshman that I knew two years
ago and Geneva Manuel who's a very
pretty girl is married to Neil Cole how
did that happen you know why did she do
that and d-bob you know say David
professor David Bob you know D Bob and
he told me you say I gave him that name
yeah nobody else he doesn't like it I
don't care but look at him all grown up
now and carrying on like he can do stuff
so okay I'm distracted from my work by
the fact that my students are here I
have something hopelessly complicated
today and so I'll just say announcer
I'll try to simplify it first I'll tell
you why I think it matters I don't think
we understand what we're up against I
don't think we're good at predicting its
ways I think we miss characterize what
it is about and I think that we do
things that make it stronger not knowing
that we do them I think of President
Bush first of all with longing of course
I mean I even long for Bill Clinton but
and I think there's never been a finer
man occupy the office than George W Bush
and I think that he didn't know the
basic terms of the controversy that were
in today and we need to know them we
need to know what's being sought and
done and I will try to say I'm provoked
in part to this because I'm in a school
of thought and several of them several
of us acting separately have been going
around saying that socialism is not what
is coming at us something else is coming
at us it's worse but it isn't socialism
and it's a mistake to think that it is I
actually believe that Obama tells the
truth when he says he doesn't want to
own General Motors I expect he's going
to sell it you know I don't think he's
going to get much for it but but I think
he he intends to sell it and the reason
is he has another ambition it's related
to socialism it's it's a cousin but it's
not the same thing I'm from Arkansas you
know we're all cousins and I actually
gave a speech in my hometown not long
ago and there's a big crowd there it's
kind of fun and I said you know we're
all cousins here but I said let me
introduce you to my first cousins there
were a lot of them too what is going on
the Democrats I was told often say these
days in the long night sessions that
they have to get their bills through on
Saturday night that they often say to
the opposition say Paul Ryan said this
yeah we're very ready to compromise
about that we want to get our
architecture in place that's what we're
going to do we've won the election we're
going to put our architecture in place
what is that architecture first of all
the original American architecture is
worth stating it is an act of obedience
in the making of our country there is
this statement about the laws of nature
and of nature's God and I think by the
way the first tool our first task in the
education of a citizen is to get to a
place where you can give a clear
definition of what those laws might be
and you can get that clear definition by
seeing how they operate in the
Declaration of Independence the people
who signed the Declaration in a much
more desperate situation than we're in
today
although ours is desperate because
remember what they were doing they were
doing something that had never been done
before you know to take on the greatest
power on earth in the name of something
that had never been a political
principle of any nation in history in
the name of the rights of every human
being including the right to be governed
only by their consent that's a
remarkable thing and they're saying that
to the king it is the Kings point the
siege of Boston was that means the siege
of the United States of America of the
city of Boston was saved by a circular
that the king wrote and had distributed
all over Boston and he managed to get it
up among our troops and what it says is
I'm gonna be really nice to you I love
you I'm your ruler I'm born to it he
thought that would
the day you know but why did he think
that he thought that because that's what
everyone thought that's what everyone
had ever thought it was the only thought
and the reaction of the colonists and
what had they done by the way except
come over here to the new world and cut
themselves off from everything and
survive and prosper and their reaction
to this thing was like the reaction
we're seeing out in the country right
now to the things happening in the city
everybody reenlist it everybody all of a
sudden there was an army again because
they read this appeal from the king you
see and if you're going to do something
so unprecedented is that so completely
wild is that you cannot appeal to any
law that any one ever passed if you're
going at the end of the Declaration to
stake your fortunes and your lives and
your sacred honor and to promise those
to each other like in this robust
promising we're going to do something we
swear to each other to do it it will be
a breach against one another if we don't
do it it's that that's what they're
right right it's a battlefield thing
it's a blood pledge to make that pledge
they have to have some Authority for
that pledge and where will they find it
because there is no authority they can't
really write to the King of England and
say my will is more important than your
will that would be such a foolish thing
to save you ever been to London you know
a king lived in a really great house and
his ancestors you know up until the time
of the last bloody change of monarchy in
England had lived in that house forever
and ever
they were a bunch of Germans who moved
in there by the
but he was a really grand guy and he had
the Divine Right of Kings on sit on his
side and so you can't write to him and
say we're gonna do what we want to do
cuz we want to do it and so they did
something stranger they subjected him to
the idea that we are the same kind of
thing as you are we are not horses and
you are not born booted and spurred to
bright us you are not an angel appointed
in the divine order to govern us you are
a man and so are we
and all men as regards governing are
created equal now that never happened
before right and you have to you have to
understand what a fixity that is you
have to understand that that is give up
your life over it and by the way the
life of George Washington was really
good when all this started out he was
becoming rapidly one of the richest men
in the United States of America and he
was the best dang farmer he ever saw he
could make money Thomas Jefferson was a
hopeless farmer he wrote these treatises
about farming and how great it was he
never could farm you know it's true he
made most of the money he managed to
make in life he made by marriage and he
made by running a nail factory you know
with slaves and I don't mean to belittle
him except a little I'm saying
he was kind of weird you know he was
really great he was a little weird
Washington had this enormous stake he
was connected to the oldest families you
know Fairfax County he was married into
that bunch see and why is that County
called that they knew the king and so
for him to say to the king
this thing once the British landed on
his farm come up the river and and
stopped by the house a force and his
brother I think it was gave them some
stuff he was mortified he was a
commander of the army at the time he
said you know you've bargained with them
you should let them burn the house
fortunes and lives and sacred honor in
the name of the laws of nature and of
nature's God now what that means really
it's explained the best it's by the way
everybody knows what it means it's
simple we're all different here some
dark some light some feminine and
beautiful and some the rest of us some
of us are old some of us are young so
we're all different right we're not the
same at all and so in what sense are we
created equal and the answer is bring a
pig in here just bring one in and
everybody a minute like if somebody
walks in the back now late there might
be a little stirring not much and we'll
glance at them and if we know them will
be interested if not we'll forget about
it in two seconds but if somebody walks
in here with a pig on the lead Wow
the pig does not belong here it is not
the
same kind of thing Douglas says to
Lincoln not Fred Douglas but Steve
Douglas assisted Lincoln's you say that
I can take my hog in my buckboard into
Nebraska and have my property protected
in it why can I not take my slave and
Lincoln replies you can if there's no
difference between the hog and the
buckboard and the slave but you know
that there is because you in the south
your friends and you he goes from
Illinois your friends in the South who
perpetuate the incision of slavery never
pass a law hanging a pig for murder but
you do slaves and you never pass a law
saying you cannot teach a hog to read
what you do slaves you know what they
are you cannot resist the knowledge what
they are it is born in you Aristotle's
account of that by the way he's a very
beautiful and fun
I'm looking around for an object I won't
do it today because it's too early in
the morning and some of you were up late
last night this was I but I will tell
you that what Aristotle says is when we
look at an object like that cup right
there we see more than any other
creature on earth sees and we see it
instantly and automatically we don't
just see that that's a white thing you
know and you might sniff it and see
what's in it knock it over we have two
dogs in our house and that is exactly
what they would do and a little short
squat want to actually find a way to get
up there and do it you know I'd make a
fool of himself what we see is come and
you know that guy's got a cup hold it up
and it's different and if that were the
cup that would not be a cup and so you
never see the cup
and yet you recognize everyone you ever
seen and that means that when you look
at the world as a human as a rational
creature you see a much richer world
than any other living creature and
because you know what category that is
in it makes you instantly available to
identify whether it is a good one or not
and so come to find out Aristotle's
but also Thomas Jefferson's argument in
the Declaration of Independence is that
everything you see is an act of sense
perception is also at the same moment an
identification of a moral world we live
in this weird world today where we think
it is proven beyond a doubt that that
hard thing is made out of moving rapidly
moving parts and then you know in movies
they're always doing this now they were
saying somebody like The Matrix was kind
of built around this idea so far as it
was built around consistent ideas that
you should be able to stick your hand in
it
because it's in motion and we think
that's an objective fact but we think
it's doubtful that I should not treat
the students at Hillsdale College the
same way I would treat my dogs I do kind
of treat them the same way but
but I expect more of the students
because the dogs are stupid and and they
respond to some of the same things but
the students are human and that means
that moral knowledge is apparent to them
at everything they see it springs up
Aristotle even says it is the reason we
can identify things what he says is the
good and being are convertible terms and
what that means is if you punched a hole
in the bottom of the cup it would not
only start being a bad cup it would also
stop being a cup and it would start
becoming a funnel that's what he says so
these laws of nature and of nature's God
are apparent to us because we can see
and they're a fixity and only humans can
see them and all humans can see them and
the wrong of slavery has always been
apparent to all who've practiced it and
that is why in any society ancient or
modern that is why in the first few
pages of Aristotle's politics slavery is
spoken of as a necessity but with
apology it is always a doubtful
institution because everybody of any
serious thinking who has looked at the
question down through history has said
it is not right unreservedly to treat a
human like it was a pig that's how
America was built and it is the first
thing in history built on that idea and
now we have a new idea and I'll try to
say what that is the new idea I'll
mention this philosopher over so I don't
know why I got up this morning out of
course I'm tired I was up too late last
night as you were what are you doing
here this morning I have to be here but
why are you here so I'm going to talk
about this philosopher what we're so
rights in the second discourse is we're
born in the state of nature and we don't
know anybody else and the first time we
run across people we invent lie
language so language is not in our
nature anymore it's a development it
arises and the key thing about human
beings that make them what they are is
not rationality the ability to see the
rich moral world implicit in the cup
it's what he calls malleability which
might be translated as chain isn't it
odd that that word should become the
master word in our politics change the
great thing about human beings is that
they change and all of a sudden were
interested in the narrative now it's not
that ancient man knew as we know that
human beings are not to be treated as
pigs it's not that when I Josh these
kids that I know so well right because
you by the way everybody before you die
you should go work in a college for a
while you'll become an expert on growing
up anyway you won't grow up but you can
watch others do it
right and they come and they look like
little kids and they leave and they look
like grown-ups and it happens in four
years precisely Neil call he looks like
a man now right he didn't used to it's
recent you know it's very funny you know
and I know his character I watch to
display itself they open up as he was
growing up right he's a good kid he went
to graduate school somewhere and he had
a moral objection to things they teach
there in the sciences for goodness sake
so he changed didn't he a weird guy it's
great see that's nature and that's by
the way why mommies and daddies matter
because when he was 21 he still needed
his mommy and daddy and other creatures
don't it's not looking at the world that
way anymore
it's looking at everything as change and
once you see that everything is in
motion and that now you are the special
creature given the gift to see that fan
are you not therefore appointed to
control the process of change what if
you could bring the tools of modern
science to bear upon human affairs what
if you could control everything what if
you could make everything right there's
a contradiction but don't don't don't
think about that for a minute the
contradiction is obvious what do you
mean by right the old guys had this idea
of nature they had this idea that in
sense perception and thinking themselves
which are the two things conjoined to
make the human being and they're not
separate they're the same in the human
being
there's only sense perception in the
animal see the idea is that makes us
that is our divine spark that is why
that we can see the difference between a
man and a beast and twinam angel and a
man right they people who think like
that they can use the term right people
who think that everything is changing
and you could get control of the process
they can't use that word I will read to
you from the president implicit in the
very idea of ordered Liberty is a
rejection of absolute truth the
infallibility of any idea or ideologies
he writes that audacity of hope' compare
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal when in
the course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands that have connected them
with another and to assume among the
powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the
laws of nature and of nature's God
entitle them the rights of mankind are
not to be rummaged for among parchments
they are written as with a sunbeam in
the whole volume of human nature that's
Hamilton it's a paraphrase that's one
way of talking this way of talking is
implicit and the very idea of ordered
Liberty is a rejection of absolute truth
and by the way this is written by a man
who seeks power and the obvious question
is what restraint will there be on its
use what principle of restraint could
there be do you like to have
conversations with eighteen-year-olds I
do it's just great especially if they're
smart and you know in our place they're
smart and it's just so much fun to
torture them because cuz you ask them
you know it's easy to get them to say
the word good and then it's easy to ask
them what it means
step1 step2 everybody the college is
used to it now so they avoid me
but it's not very big so you can't get
away and you'll say you know you said
good what does that mean and they'll say
you know they say they learn the
standard answers don't work but the
standard answers are well doing what you
think is right you know because the
modern mind doesn't want to say anything
is right and so I always bring up Hitler
Hitler's handy in this regard I always
say you know he didn't really thought he
was right you know he was going for it
or as the white who's that
press lady at the White House who says
that Mao lived his dream Don is that her
name and she reads him every day she
living her dream right how are you gonna
criticize that if everything is change
and the tools of science are to be used
to control the process have you wondered
why those climatologists guys in England
should be such liars
because it's counterintuitive isn't it
just think what they are right first of
all they're very intelligent people
second of all they have they have
survived two decades no three decades of
serious academic work challenging
difficult hard demanding enormous
virtues of perseverance and seriousness
they are at the top of their field
how can they be just simple liars that
they are liars is clear but can they
really be just simple Liars in their own
mind are they in the wrong it's not
possible to think that if you just think
about them for a minute right what they
are instead is pioneers of a new world
in which science is wedded to
administration and everything can be
managed and perfected and they know they
must know that global warming is a
stalking horse for that kind of regime
it is part of the architecture that is
being
built and that means that you do not
have to own things if you can regulate
them in any way that you please indeed
it's not a good idea to own things
because what would you regulate what
will it be like it's coming first of all
community organizing is going to be a
big deal it is a miserable experience to
be organized I'm gonna mention the book
1984 it's an extreme thing to say in one
way and I don't mean to say that these
people imagine a world like that at all
but I want to mention a particular
feature of the book if you want to
understand by the way the totalitarian
impulse the to bless places I know to
read it I mean you can read marks and
stuff if you want to I did and I got
over it read 1984 Orwell a communist who
reformed and was horrified by what he
was involved in and read darkness at
noon by Arthur Koestler
another of the same time but in 1984
what's going on there these three
parties right there are these three
groups of people that appear
it's a regime in three parts and the
proletariat they're left alone and
they're happy the great thing is to be
one of them they the only appear well
they appear as poor they appear as a
prostitute in one case a poor old ugly
prostitute living a miserable existence
but then the big study of them is when
they're Winston Smith and his mistress
are in their secret room by the way
where they get to have privacy see and
that's what you cannot have you cannot
turn off the television what we're ports
seem like you today
to you today I cannot bear I use I have
like four sets of fancy headphones and
and now once in a while the lady on the
airplane will say you know sir you can't
you can't really have that in while
we're talking and I will say but yeah
that's why I want to have it in to
engage in public transportation today is
to be lectured and ordered about
wherever you going you know I do it all
the time today I'll be doing it you
can't turn off the television Winston
and his and his girlfriend look out the
window and there's a lady and she's
singing an old ditty
and it's vaguely resonant with them and
she's hanging up clothes it's
beautifully described and and she's
living normally she's unaffected the
hope Winston Smith thinks is in them and
the other two parts of the regime are
the active parts the inner party a world
of despots struggling one against the
other for power over the outer party
which is what Winston Smith is and the
outer party are the people who are
regimented they are made to exercise
early in the morning they can't get a
razor blade they have to listen to a
television all the time and by the way
if they don't do what's supposed to the
person on television can see them and
will talk to them and make them do their
exercises better and stuff like that now
I mentioned that because a regime like
that is imagined it's kindly imagined in
that regime there's most of us and
according to American progressivism we
get to rule we get to decide ideas are
proposed to us from an active scientific
and technical administration of very
large size and we hear these ideas and
we vote once in a while kind
like a big pleb site and we decide
whether this will be implemented or not
but the process can't get dangerous for
the administration because the
government has become such a
considerable force that it's not
impossible what was that
is it the Heritage Foundation sign or
ours I'm a trustee of the Heritage
Foundation and fully entitled to speak
under its banner and we'll proceed in
that vein so I'm nearly finished now but
if there's a corn is there more going
down thank you dear
there you go thank you it if there's if
there's why you know by the way why were
they outraged that Sarah Palin said kind
of like a community organizer but with
real responsibilities you wouldn't know
it I didn't know it but there's a class
a person who does that and it's a large
class and it's a powerful class acorn is
by the way a very large body of people
funded by the government to work upon us
to influence elections to influence the
government in its decisions to bring
lawsuits against corporations to make
them behave the way it thinks they
should and the government then has
actually appointed people to work upon
us and that is a direct abnegation of
the central arrangement of our old
regime which is that the society is
separate from the government and
sovereignty is located in the society
look at the health care thing it's the
public option is not a separate thing
it's all the public option you know I
got mr. Carville to look it up because I
keep hearing that it's gonna be
unionized
the whole healthcare in she's gonna be
unionized how would that work personal
care attendants workforce advisory panel
that will likely impose union
affiliation to qualify for a newly
created by the way who could ever room I
have to read these words I read them
this morning I can't remember them and
you know I I have a fair memory I can
remember Hamilton personal care
attendants workforce Advisory Panel
impose union affiliation to qualify for
a newly created community living
assistant services and support class
can anyone assign any meaning to those
terms you know they don't mean anything
it's a new world created by the will of
man and things are not descriptive
teacher Minister surgeon nurse you know
what those are right those are things in
nature you know as long as there's been
people there's been those things right
personal care attendants workforce
advisory panel the way you do
broadcasting is that you form an
advisory panel and they decide who gets
a license and licenses have to be
renewed every other year and the word
and the advisory panel represents all of
the diversity groups you see and then
they meet and they decide if your
programming has been good enough to
qualify and of course their union reps
and there are so so you meet in a group
I used to say at the air cries to fight
with the Air Quality Management District
in Southern California it's a it's awful
they had 1200 employees and they had a
hundred of them doing PR probably they
got 2,000 or 3,000 now and I used to
argue with them a lot I went to me at
the Claremont is did we once made them
take back a rule and their whole idea I
said you know I'm going to
body parts organization because every
time you do you guys do a panel
you got the Lung Association and the
Heart Association and uh you know all
the different stakeholders they call
them that's a term from Hegel and they
all get together and they all by the way
have an interest because they're all
grantees when I started causing them
trouble
they said they called me in and said
would you come and visit the director
and the chief of community relations I
said sure I'll go down there and so we
had a long talk and they said you know
this is really interesting what you're
doing here we'd like to have your help
and I said well you know you got it and
they said well we'd like to give you a
grant and I said well you know I don't
really want a grand they said but you
know you you we'd like to have your help
and I said you're gonna get it you know
you see but they at one point she said I
don't understand one thing she said she
said you say that we spend too much
money because you know the way these
things are funded all these local
regulatory agencies on the environmental
stuff they're funded by the fees and
fines that they impose on the regulated
community and so they find you and if
you don't like it you appeal to them
right and they're living off the revenue
they get from you and you've got reason
not to put to it to protest about it and
she said you say that we've got too much
money but then you want us to charge
instead of regulating he wants to charge
for pollutants and I said correct that's
what I want you to do I mean if you're
gonna do it that way everybody will see
the cost and the market can adjust and
that takes you our discretion out of it
but she said what are we gonna do with
the extra money and I said well there
might not be any extra money and she
said why and I said it's the difference
between a regulatory and a Revenue
tariff regulatory tariffs are high and
they don't yield much money what you're
trying to do is keep the good sound
revenue tariffs are low a lot of goods
come in you get a lot of dough and this
woman said to me wow that's brilliant
and I replied no ma'am that is
Elementary
you see but the point is in your
dealings with the government your
interest is married to quote Woodrow
Wilson to the interest of the government
and so you lose the one thing that you
must lose and under the regulatory state
the one thing that everyone will lose
which is their independence
you can keep your ownership of your
property you will hold it on title from
us in all of your use of it and that by
the way is the economic principle of
feudalism born again in this country and
I will stop by saying that there are two
things to do about this and they're easy
to state the first is we have to develop
a clear way of talking about this that
is accurate we have to study the laws of
nature and of nature's God so that we
can say what they are and we have to
study the bureaucratic way so we can
describe it as it is we have to do that
relentlessly we have to start producing
not big administrative bureaucratic
platforms from both parties but short
and simple and beautiful platforms from
one party which everyone turns out not
to be evil right now they're both evil
and both stupid we have to produce clear
and simple and beautiful laws and when
we get ourselves to an intellectual
state where we can produce that kind of
thing then we have to talk with all our
might and all our eloquence and all our
hearts to our fellow citizens because
they alone can save their freedom there
are are two tasks and there are no
others thank you
we have time for a few questions if you
would for the benefit of the recording
wait until the microphone comes to you
and then stand up and address your short
question doctrinal be pleased to answer
it any questions this is sort of a
constitutional question when since you
quoted Hamilton so often when Hamilton
was arguing with Madison and Jefferson
over the establishment of the first bank
he used I believe the general welfare
clause is his justification for that do
you think that in some ways he won that
battle of lost the war well yeah yeah in
some ways he did but do you understand
what the issue is is in article 1
section 8 there's 17 clauses and they're
all specific except the first and the
specific ones are things like coin money
and regulate the value thereof and you
know go kill pirates is one of them I
don't think they put it quite that way
but that's what they meant and and then
you know necessary and proper to the
general welfare right is that how it
reads so the point is here's my answer
to that the Constitution we have to in
my opinion it's not as important to
conceive it as a specific set of
prohibitions and and empowerment's that
comes second the first thing is to
understand its grand structure because
the Constitution from the first days was
fraught with hard cases Jefferson
struggles over whether you can build a
harbor to defend the port of Boston
right there's no build a harbor right
you can't read that in there but there's
defense is that okay he kind of wants to
say you can't do it but then he stuck by
in Louisiana so so the truth is the
Constitution can be read intelligently
if you understand its large purpose
which is to keep the federal government
to a few grand things and by the way to
have a lot of power over those but to
have almost no administrative power over
our ordinary daily lives and I'll make
the distinction before you for you the
biggest subsidy ever given in education
is in the Northwest Ordinance
second-biggest is in the land-grant
colleges act in 1862 and in both of
those what they do is they take a
section of the western lands their idea
about the western lands being to get it
into private hands as fast as they could
and they reserve it for education but
the but but the the vehicle is and this
is so beautiful by the way if you go if
you go read the Morell act it's called
the land-grant colleges Act the
Homestead Act or the Northwest Ordinance
I think the longest of those is five
pages long and they're lovely documents
you know the Northwest Ordinance says
religion morality and knowledge being
necessarily good government and the
happiness of mankind schools and the
means of education shall ever be
encouraged how do you do it the answer
is you got this asset give it to the
state on condition that the state use it
for the purpose of education end of
story there is no one to whom the state
could report now if they abuse the
privilege I imagine somebody could sue
in federal court and say you know you
got this for this but now you use it for
that you know this in the Northwest
Ordinance in the land ordinance of 1785
it's the 16th section of each township
of 36 sections that is reserved for
education I know where that is in
Hillsdale Michigan it's just a little
bit north and a little bit east of our
campus and if you go follow the deeds
all the way back and they will exist all
the way back you will see that at one
point that land
to the state and the state either
devoted to education or sold it and used
the money for education if they didn't
do that you consume and so there's no
administrative authority over anything
local or detailed and concerning the
regular citizens of the country in
Washington DC and if you can achieve
that again then this question about the
bank and about the harbor and about the
Louisiana Purchase won't matter so much
because the heart of the evil that we
have today is this enormous
administrative class the bureaucracy
which is large enough to interfere with
everything and powerful and large enough
to influence the outcome of elections so
now all of a sudden elections become
powerfully influenced and eventually may
be dominated by people who are really
judging in their own cause what I mean
by that they vote the way they get so
you see that's my point
and my point then is the Constitution in
the grand sense and I mean the whole of
it the structure of it with its division
of powers and you know of its division
of labor between the branches it's you
know because here's another accident
from the Constitution the Constitution
convention is called because Madison and
Hamilton in the Maine are concerned
about violation of Rights and States
they want a strong government they
actually agree although you know they
later fight like cats and dogs over
stuff like this they agree at the
convention and proposed that the
government of the United States should
be empowered to legislate in all cases
whatsoever now these guys by the way
there's no way they're trying to build a
despotism look who they are look how
they risk their lives look at the
treason they had committed right so
their idea is we need a strong federal
government
to legislate wherever it needs for the
great national purposes they can't get
that through the convention because
there's the other party is saying no
states are very important we don't want
to give it up we're not gonna build a
thing like the King of England again and
what is worked out it's not so much the
grand compromise of the Bill of Rights
although that's important what's worked
out is the system of enumeration
reinforced by the system of states
electing senators by state legislatures
which gives States a tool to defend
their authorities my argument is states
don't have rights people do and and you
know that means by the way that the 17th
amendment is the worst amendment ever
passed if you could get back to that
world then it wouldn't matter very much
how strictly you interpreted the 17
clauses it's the fact of them and the
indication of them in general and then
the lack of a federal domestic
bureaucracy that our protection should
be in that make sense okay
Lyndsay Hoban US Court of Federal Claims
could you explain how the apparent value
of humanity applies to abortion and
embryonic stem cell research well human
life has a different in higher dignity
than other life although all life has a
dignity and animal life for sure which
has sense perception memory and
intelligence is not to be abused but
human life is special because it is
immortal and what immortal means in the
religious sense is not what you need it
to mean here what you need it to mean
here is it is aware of the eternal and
lives its life in accordance with that
and the universal in its ordinary
operation and so it was made with a
power that is divine and beyond any
particular situation it's human beings
are odd creatures you should read I just
I'm just finishing a class on the
Nicomachean ethics of Aristotle and it's
such a beautiful experience to do that
you know the kids are real smart and and
we just are having just a fantastic time
because the we're we're in next next
class is the last class and it's on book
ten and we actually somehow got through
it for the second time in my experience
and books 8 9 and 10 are about
friendship happiness and pleasure and
they're the culmination of the great
book and in the book what's described is
that pleasure in the beginning of the
book is suspicious suspected it's
demoted it's confined it's told you're
told not to listen to it at the end it's
purified and it becomes the point of
your life the point of your life is the
feeling of you of the active proper
activity of your being
but you're a compound being and so this
highest things in us like you know when
when if we've had a moment this morning
where we're thinking about things quite
beyond ourselves things that are high
and beautiful and we maybe have had one
last night we probably did if you were
there that's the best thing in us but we
also have all these needs well it's
these needs that we have that lead us to
hurt each other and damage each other
but we ought not to do that and that
means that the details of things like
that those are those questions of
abortion and stem-cell research is that
you must not treat human making as a
manufacturing process you must not treat
a human being a life and well-being of
another human being as a factor of
production in your own well-being
because that is like slavery so that's
how you think about it broadly
this will be our final question I'm
undoubtedly fascinated by the
intellectual analysis of the situation
with President Obama but I don't think
and this is just my humble opinion that
we have time to develop a whole class a
citizenry that can approach overturning
what's happening within the time that we
have
so other than sewage which will happen
in about a year and hopefully we will be
able to turn around some of the things
that are happening what would your
recommendation be for people like me
that are out there in contact with you
know activists and even our children and
our children's friends and you know our
children's parents to somehow steer the
country in the right direction
good question so I'll just say a few
points first of all we don't have to
develop a class of citizens who have
these basic points in their mind they're
already exist in a considerable majority
and they've proved it in recent weeks
this stuff that I just told you is all
kind of fancy and sophisticated I used
to say to my dad before he died my dad's
a school teacher in Arkansas and I had
my young and stupid period now I have my
old and stupid period but I used to
argue with him about stuff when I was in
college because I had you know about 18
months where I was pretty liberal and
later in life one of the greatest
satisfactions I gave him was that I said
you know it's been a long time dad now
learning complicated reasons why you
were right he he loved that right and I
have more complicated reasons than he
had but where did my father get his
education he got
from undergraduate college you know and
by the way they're not very good at
teaching and undergraduate college these
days that's a blessing I mean that it
really is they can't the stuff they're
trying to teach it's so counterintuitive
the kids have to be really brilliant and
have a little bit of a despotic ambition
in them to take to it right must don't
and then my dad you know he grew up on a
farm and the depression and he was a
hunter and he had three children and he
got himself through college and he
served in the Army and he made my mother
and they were married for 53 years and
he watched us grow up and most of us
have you know somehow managed to work
out okay in other words he got his
education from life and it's very hard
to get around that most people are not
gonna gonna get the fancy education that
made Liars out of those elite scientists
in England and that's one reason why the
populace of America are so stubborn
about this stuff so I don't expect
everybody in the country to follow the
argument I just made I can hardly follow
it myself as you could tell what we need
is simple we we have the force in the
society to turn all this back they need
some leadership they need some people
who can think and to have courage and
are high-minded to take the lead and
that by the way those people are in
office right now I named several of them
there you know I just had an inspiring
couple of days right and a lot of those
people I've known for a long time their
characters are fantastic and they're not
on the list of people who might run for
president one of them might run actually
pins from Indiana says he might run
here's what he says he's such a such a
self effacing fine talented guy he says
I was saying for a long time that I have
a calling not to run for president and
I'm not saying that anymore
which is not saying he's got a calling
to do it right and he means that he's
very self restrained man so there's two
jobs right and one is whip up the people
communicate with them you know and to
the extent you can teach them about the
meaning of their country you know we do
that we're gonna have an online course
so everybody understand the Constitution
and it'll be simple and complex
depending on how far you go but then the
other thing is find some people who are
really great and try to get them into
positions of influence so I'm gonna try
to make a few congressmen famous and I
go around to them I might as you can
tell I'm a frightful lecturer I've just
I've been ruined by my job in one
respect that I had a native tendency
that way anyway so I go and sit with
these powerful people and tell them how
they ought to do their work
and they like it you know I don't do at
least they asked me back and they do
because they know I love them and one of
the things I tell them as friendship is
the deal so you guys all have to get
together and work and you got to not
care who gets elected governor and
Attorney General and president you've
got to serve now country really needs
you it needs the best in you it needs
your selflessness in your high
mindedness and your cooperation and they
know that you know who are they I'll
name them Paul Ryan Mike Pence Tom
McClintock John Shattuck I'm forgetting
something now that there's you know 15
20 30 of them maybe 40 Fortenberry I
just met him yesterday
walking down the hall sort of Nebraska
it's just great so the point is they you
know so by the way the two elements
necessary are in place they're just not
in the right order now it matters a lot
the next two or three or four months
everything should be done you know I
actually just hesitated to say this but
I'm a citizen I'm gonna say it it is my
personal recommendation as a city
and not deploying the resources of any
organization represented here that it is
very urgent Meritor first to delay and
then to defeat this bill that's going
through the Senate right now if it can
be delayed it might be beaten and it
will be mighty good for the country if
it can be beaten because it will put
infrastructure in place that will be
terribly hard to repeal but never say
that it will not be repealed so there
you go
and remember you don't what I just made
today I'll close with this point was a
defense of common sense and we've all
got that don't we